the subject matter and the complexity
determines what program I start using
illustrator is a vector program so it's
good for schematic things and things
that have flat shapes and aren't too too
complex for things that have a lot more
shading and organic form to them I like
to paint it in Photoshop and for more
realistic things cinema 4d is great for
anything 3d you want the person just by
looking at it to get a sense of the mood
and the message being conveyed a lot of
times we don't know what these things
look like with these proteins and these
molecules look like and because they
exist below the wavelength of light
there's no color there so color is a big
decision it has a lot to do with where
you position things on the page as well
little visual cues like that a lot of
times the end product could end up
looking completely different from that
original sketch and that original idea
I try I have to try to change it up now
I can just draw mice out of my head I
don't even have to look at pictures